Let's go next to a Joey and Chicago.
We haven't heard from Joey in Chicago since
may.
Hey David.
How's it going?
Good.
How are you?
Um, so I just want to get your thought.
Do you think there's any chance that Donald
Trump would resign?
Uh, I mean I've said before, I think if someone
sits him down and it's really getting bad
and someone says you are going to be removed,
I think it's possible that he would, but I
think that his ego would make them hold out
until the absolute last possible second.
Yeah, for sure.
That's what I was saying.
Just cause you know, you see everything happening
and like how bad it is getting.
And you know, I just watched one of your videos
about all the GOP people that are backing
impeachment and it's like he's eventually
going to run out of Republicans, hopefully.
Well remember the story I did was that there's
the idea that if the, if the impeachment vote,
if the conviction vote were private, Republicans
might support it, but it's not private.
So I don't actually think you're going to
see Republican support is removal.
Yeah, for sure.
All right.
Well, yeah, that's, uh, that's it man.
Thanks a lot for everything that you do.
Okay.
Joey in Chicago.
Great to hear from you.